told your mother i could take good care
of you
i love you more than anyone in this
whole wide world
[Music]
her mom was dead she'll be better off
here no she won't
what's her name
you can call her whatever you want
you'll be my little angel from now on
angel
how did you end up with this place she
doesn't talk about her past
you got any plans
plans
[Music]
she can't keep me here
you forget where i found you missy
i made you a princess
feel the power ranger
the only girls who leave here are too
old too sick to work
they're dead
i'm gonna kill you
[Music]
[Music]
no one gets within a foot of her for
free
i have to meet her
what's your pleasure mister
i didn't come here for
that i
[Music]
you're gonna heard me
take me away from here
give me the life i deserve
i've got too many demons i don't know
how to love
you did not you lose the life you have
but you can choose the life you want
he deserves a decent girl not you
did you think i couldn't find you
you have to stop thinking that i'm gonna
be something that i'm not
that way is home
your choice
you
[Music]
[Music]